رئاسه مجلس الامن لشهر الحالي واشكر السيد
رئيس لجنه العقوبات على تقريره ربع سنوي
السيدات والساده
الاثر الاقليمي للاحداث
بالرغم من ان القرار 151 منحصر على اقليم
دارفور ولكن اذا اعتبر ان الاحداث الاخيره
وتدفقات النازحين ذات اثر متعدي فاننا نرى
التالي لم تتاثر علاقات السودان مع جيرانه
بسبب الاوضاع الانسانيه وان كان لكل
اشتباكات عسكريه اثار سلبيه بالضروره
ولم يتلقى السودان اجعارا بان النازحين
واللاجئين الذين وصلوا حدود بعض الدول قد
تسببوا في افلات الامن القومي
هناك محاولات لتهريب اسلحه نوعيه من شاكلت
صواريخ مضاده للطائرات لدعم التمرد ولكن
القوات الامنيه السودانيه تراقب ذلك
باسرار
ان معظم الدول
التزمت الحياده الايجابي لا سيما ان تشاد
اغلقت الحدود لمنع تسرب قوات التمرد الى
اراضيها واعتقلت الذين نفذوا اليها واخسرت
السودان بذلك هناك تقارير بتورط ومشاركه
لبعض فصائل المعارضه الشاديه مع قوات
التمرد ونشكر الحكومه التشاديه على
تعاونها في هذا المجال
وفيما يخص اوضاع اللاجئين السودانيين في
تشاد وبالتحديد في معسكرات والداي سيلا
واديفيرا ان الحكومه التشاديه تؤكد
تضامنها مع السودان حيث يبلغ تعداد
اللاجئين السودانيين الذين نزحوا اليها
بعد الانتهاكات التي اقترفها اقترفتها
الميليشيا 113 الف في الولايات الثلاث
ويلقون ترحيبا من المجتمعات المحليه
العائدون منهم حوالي 25 الفا ومعظمهم من
النساء والاطفال
وفيما يتعلق بالحدود الشماليه الغربيه
للسودان قد تشهد ايصال مساعدات مثل
تموينات القتال مناصره لقوات التمرد
واما بشان الحدود مع افريقيا الوسطى فهي
مفتوحه وهادئه ولكن هناك مساعي من قبل
قوات التمرد الاستغلالها
كما ساوضح
حدودنا مع جمهوريه مصر العربيه هادئه
ومفتوحه وقد استقبلت مصر
الالاف من المواطنين عقب الاحداث الحاليه
ونشكر القياده والشعب المصري على ذلك على
الحدود الاثيوبيه الامن مستتب ولا يوجد ما
يشير الى تاثر امنها القومي بفعل الاحداث
وفتحت ابوابها لاستقبال اللاجئين مع قله
الاعداد التي وصلت الى هناك ولقد اشارت
بعد الوفود بالمجلس في جلسه في جلسه سابقه
الى احتمال تدهور العلاقات بين السودان
وجنوب السودان بفعل عوده اللاجئين
الجنوبيين الا ان ذلك لم يحدث المعلومات
التي تلقيناها من اوضاع اللاجئين من جنوب
السودان
بمحليه الجبلين الحدوديه تشير الى استضافه
الولايه لاكثر من 365 الف لاجئ
منهم حوالي 220 الف وصلوا الى المنطقه من
الخرطوم بعد الاشتباكات الاخيره واستقروا
في معسكرات محليه وذلك وفقا لاخر احصائيه
رسميه اجريت في العاشر من شهر مايو الماضي
وفيما يخص الوضعيه الانسانيه في اقليم
دارفور فقد تم توزيع كميات كبيره من
المساعدات الانسانيه والصحيه من قبل
برنامج الغذاء العالمي في مناطق وسط
دارفور وشمال وغرب جبل مره
وادي صالح
وفي جنوب دارفور في مناطق النياله وكاس
وجريده وبلال وفي جنوب كردفان في ابو
جبيهه وابو كرشوله وديلامي والدلنج
والليري وجدير وكادوقلي ورشاد وثالودي وفي
وسط دارفورد بلغ عدد المستفيدين من
الاغاثه الانسانيه 101 الف شخص 617 وفي
شرق دارفول
وفي شرق دارفور بلغ عددهم 33 الف وميه
وعشرين شخص وفي شمال دارفور بلغ عددهم
143,946 وفي جنوب دارفور بلغ عددهم 89,769
وفيما يخص الوضعيه الانسانيه الراهنه في
وسط وغرب وشرق دارفور اي مثلث الجنينه
زالينجي ونيالا ان اعتداءات ميليشياء
الميليشيا المتمرده على القوات المسلحه
واعتداءات المتحالفه معها على السكان في
ولايه دارفور لاسيما في مدينه جنينه حاضره
ولايه غربي دارفور افرزت واقعا انسانيه
رهيبا حيث يجري استهداف المدنيين بالهويه
وتمت تدمير البنيات التحتيه اللازمه
لتوفير الخدمات الاساسيه ان هذا الواقع
يتطلب استجابه انسانيه عاجله وفي هذا
الصدد نعرب على الشكر والتقدير لكافه
الدول الشقيقه والصديقه والمنظمات الدوليه
والاقليميه والحكوميه وغير الحكوميه
ومنظمات المجتمع المدني المحليه والاجنبيه
التي استجابت للنداء الانساني الذي اطلقته
حكومه السودان وساهمت في تقديم المساعدات
بصفه عاجله الامر الذي كان له اثر كبير في
تخفيف حده الازمه الان والاستجابه للطوارئ
لكن ذلك يتطلب المزيد خاصه في ولايه غربي
دارفور التي شهدت احداثا جساما يؤسفني ان
ابلغ مجلسكم الموقر ان الميليشيات
المسنود بقوات من الدعم السريع اعتقلت
واختفت والي ولايه غرب دارفور الاستاذ
خميس عبدالله بكر يوم امس ثم قامت بقتله
والتبشيع بجسمانه جدير بالذكر ان الاستاذ
خميس يمثل احد الاطراف الموقعه على
اتفاقيه جبل السلام ونترحم على روحه وهو
التزم موقف الحياه اسوه بغيره من اطراف
التي وقعت على اتفاقيه
ان الحكومه السودانيه تؤكد التزامها
بتسهيل دخول وحركه العاملين في الحقل
الانساني ومنحهم تاشيرات الدخول والتصاريح
اللازمه وتامين سلامتهم لاداء مهمهم
الانسانيه على الوجه المطلوب كذلك ستواصل
في تسهيل الاجراءات الخاصه
بدخول المساعدات من الموانئ والمطارات
وامكانيه نقلها وتوزيعها وفقا لخارطه
الاحتياجات لكل الولايات المتاثره بالازمه
ونشدد على ضروره ممارسه اقصى درجات الضغط
على القوات المتمرده والمليشيات المتحالفه
معها من اجل واخف جرائمها واعتدائها
والزامها بتسهيل المسارات الانسانيه وعدم
التعرض لقوافل المساعدات الانسانيه وازاله
مظاهر الوجود العسكري في مناطق التجمعات
السكنيه والخدميه
وفيما يخص وضعيه القرار 15 واحد وتسعين
لقد ذكرنا في مرات سابقه للمجلس ان القرار
15 واحد وتسعين قساهم في اضعاف هيبه وحضور
الدوله في اقليم دارفور وفي الحفاظ على
الامن وحمايه المدنيين بسبب الحظر المفروض
على السلاح على القوات المسلحه مما ادى
الى ترجيح كفه المجموعات المسلحه وتقييد
جهود الحكومه في حفظ الامن ونعتقد بان عدم
توفر الدعم المالي والوفاء بتعهدات
المجتمع الدولي لدعم عمليات نزع السلاح
والتسريح
واعاده الدمج لمقاتل الحركات المسلحه
واطراف اتفاقيه جبه قد اثر ايضا على تنفيذ
الاتفاقيه بطريقه مرضيه وان تواجد قوات
التمرد في اقليم دارفور وهم مدججين
بالسلاح مدعاه للقلق
فقد ثبت مشاركه عناصر اجنبيه في تركيبه
مقاتلي الميليشيا ومنهم من جهر باخذ
فيديوهات خلال مشاركتهم في القتال مع
العثور على اسلحه متقدمه وذكيه تم تسريبها
الى معسكر طيبه الخاص بقوات الميليشيا عثر
عثر عليها في حاويات محصنه تحت الارض
السيد الرئيسه ان العنف المشتمل على النهب
الواسع النطاق وحرق المساكن والمرافق
العامه والمؤسسات الحكوميه وتدمير البنى
التحتيه والاسواق والمدارس والمستشفيات
ومخازن الادويه هي كلها جرائم ارتكبتها
الميليشيات وهناك ايضا استهداف للمواقع
العسكريه التابعه للقوات المسلحه في
دارفور اضافه الى استهداف مطارات وجسور في
حاله
ان نمط جرائم الميليشيا تكرر بنفس الوتيره
لهدم الدوله السودانيه في المركز والهامش
وذلك بالطواطئ
مع جهات سيتم الكشف عنها في وقت لاحق هذا
العنصر لا بد من الاشاره اليه في التقارير
الامميه لان الحياده امام جرائم زرقا الى
مرتبه جرائم الحرب وجرائم ضد الانسانيه
يعتبر تشجيعا للاستمرار في ارتكاب هذه
الفظائع ان اللاجئين الذين وفدوا الى تشاد
كان سبب نزوهم يعزى لهجمات الميليشيا
المبرمجه لافراق المكون الديموغرافي ووضع
اليد على الارض بمثل ما فعلته بانتهاك
حرمه الملكيه وحق الحياه ووضع السكان في
ظروف معيشيه فضه وهذا يندرج تحت طائله
القانون الدولي ان الفجوه الامنيه التي
ادت الى تفاقم الاشتباكات القبليه في
دارفور وما اسفرت عنه من المواجهات ما كان
ذلك ليحدث لو تم القاء القرار 15 91
المتطاول الامد الذي عمل على اضعاف القوات
المسلحه السودانيه ودورها في حمايه
المواطنين في دارفور لدرجه ان الميليشيا
استهدفت القوه المشتركه المكونه بين تشاد
والسودان واستهدفت قبائل بعينها من قبل
ميليشيا واستهدفت قبائل بعينها من قبل
الميليشيا لدرجه ان المليشيا منعت حتى
ادلاء الجرحى والمصابين بعد ان دمرت
المستشفيات وان الميليشيا وحلفائها كانوا
يقتحمون البيوتات بابا تلو باب مع قوائم
معده سلفا للمستهدفين ان الجرائم المرتكبه
في الخرطوم ودارفور واستهدافي وتقتيل سكان
تهديف السكان خلال حرب خلال الحرب الراهنه
انما تكرر الان في سيناريو انما تكرر الان
في سيناريو القتل على الهويه الاثنيه
وفيما يتعلق بالسلامه الاهلي
نطلب في هذا السياق من الامم المتحده دعم
جهود السلام الاهلي بموازات جهود الرسميه
التي تبذلها حكومه السودان هناك جهود
اهليه اخرى تقوم بها منظمات المجتمع
المدني من اجل تهدئه الاوضاع ومعالجه
الاثار الحرب في هذا الاطار وقعت المكونات
المدنيه بولايه جنوب دارفور وثيقه عقد
اجتماعي وتراضي مجتمعي ضمت
80 قبيله بالولايه وذلك ضمن جهود المبادره
المجتمعيه بالولايه لوقف الحرب واعاده
الحياه المدنيه
ولمعالجه الاوضاع بمدينه جنينه وولايه غرب
دارفور انعقد اجتماع طارئ ضم حاكم اقليم
دارفور مع ولايه مع ولاه ولايات دارفور
حيث سيقوم الولاه او قام الولاه برئاسه
حاكم الاقليم بزاره الى الجنينه حاضره
ولايه غرب دارفور باستصحاب المتطوعين
برئاسه من الكوادر الطبيه والادارات
الاهليه والمنظمات الوطنيه والمبادرون
للوقوف ميدانيا على الاوضاع الامنيه
والانسانيه والعمل مع سلطات الولايه لنزع
فتيل
الازمه واستدباب الامن وتحقيق السلام بعد
الاحداث الدمويه التي شهدتها الولايه على
مدار الايام الماضيه كما تم ارسال الادويه
والمواد الايوائيه الموجوده ببورسودان عبر
مطاريها الفاشر ونيالا لتوزيعه على
المتضررين اضافه الى تامين كل الطرق
الداخليه والقوميه منه الى دارفور وهذا ما
يستدعي ان تكون الاولويه لعمليات بناء
السلام وتوفير دعم اللازم لترسيها خلال
المرحله القادمه والنوعيه لبعث
السيده الرئيسه ان قوات الميليشيا تعمل
الان على محاصره منطقه ام دافوك الحدوديه
بين افريقيا الوسطى
والسودان وهذا
قبل حلول موسم الخريف بهدف نشر اليات لها
هناك وهذا العنصر مدعاه للقلق حيث سيترجم
الى سلسله من الهجمات النوعيه التي تستهدف
القتل على الهويه ونحن نحذر من ان عدم
ادانه هذه العمليات سوف يخلق غول يهدد
الامن من الخرطوم الى الساحل وهذا سيتحمله
صمت المجتمع الدولي عن ادانه هذه الاحداث
النابيه واننا نلاحظ ان هناك محاولات لربط
جنوب ليبيا مع منطقه ام دافوك بهدف نقل
اليات حربيه لدعم المجهود الحربي لقوات
المليشيا
اما فيما يتعلق بوحده مكافحه العنف ضد
المراه والطفل ان عناصر الميليشيا
وتحرشاتها ضد النساء ادت الى ارتفاع مستوى
حالات العنف الجنسي المتصل بالنزاع في
الخرطوم ولم ترد اي تحديثات بشان اقليم
دارفور ان الميليشيات تمارس جرائم الخطف
وتطالب بدفع فديه ماليه كبيره ان
الميليشيات استهدفت اي دبلوماسي او سفير
سوداني ادلى بتصريح ضدها اجتهدفت بيت
ونهبت ممتلكاته ان وحده مكافحه العهد ضد
المراه والطفل تشير الى زياده جرائم الخطف
والعنف الجنسي الجماعي في الخرطوم والتي
تستهدف صغيرات السن من الفتيات وفي غالب
تلك الجرائم اكدت اصابع الاتهام الى قوات
ترتدي زي الدعم السريع وفقا لافادات
الشهود وان هذه الوحده تقوم بتوثيق هذه
الجرائم بهدف انهاء الافلات من العقاب
اشكركم على حسن الاستماع شكرا سيد الرئيس
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات